au coeur de la cité universitaire du
tampon le bâtiment du centre
international d'études pédagogiques
signe ce jour-là une convention avec le
département contribue bien aux côtés de
l'état à la stratégie de coopération
éducative que la france réunion si vous
permettez une en france et au
développement
une francophonie de proxy si vous pensez
qu'il s'agit d'une simple signature
administrative alors direction tuléar
voir un cas concret à l'argon d'eloïse
qui a été formé dans ce cep de parler
maîtriser la langue nous avons la
capacité à m'adapter à m'adapter
un milieu à une culture
comme des dizaines d'autres réunionnais
et loïs fait rayonner le français dans
l'océan indien et par la même occasion
trace son chemin professionnel je suis
quoi relation à distance et en même
temps toujours facile
[Musique]
retour au centre international d'études
pédagogiques ou héloïse comme près de
300 étudiants se sont formés en 2018
peur de la coopération ne s'improvise
pas ce n'est pas parce qu'on a envie de
faire des projets à l'étranger qu'on
peut le faire
nous nous sommes un opérateur pour cela
nous sommes un exécuteur nous savons
mettre en oeuvre des projets pour
l'international nous avons mobilisé de
l' expertise et des financements pour
mettre en oeuvre des projets à
l'international ainsi à la signature de
cet accord cadre de partenariat
la vision se veut collective ça veut
dire que les choses ont raté au fur et à
mesure et quelles que soient les élus
qui sont là les mots de passe c'est de
partir en ordre dispersé partir tous
ensemble tous les opérateurs du
ministère d'éducation nationale mais
aussi de l'europe les affaires
étrangères et puis les principaux
bailleurs comme l'afd vous savez que la
sève des viandes rejoindre la réunion on
a une vocation naturelle à travailler
ensemble
donc l'idée est bien ça on est collectif
on joue collectif on est une équipe de
france de l'éducation et on la fera
briller à la réunion le département
structure sa politique de coopération
dans l'océan indien
toute politique a besoin d'outils ici
nous sommes au à l'université du tampon
qui héberge justement ce centre de
formation international
c'est un outil nous nous n'aurions pas
réussi s'il n'avions pas cet outil notre
jeanne aurait dû aller en métropole pour
se former dans un centre c'est le seul
centre international d'apprentissage du
français dans le monde hors de la france
hexagonale
le tampon et lé député maire de l'époque
on disait qu'on avait bien compris ce
centre venait de l'intérieur de
l'afrique
il a su le capter sur la réunion et
aujourd'hui cette réunion devient veut
dire le carrefour des langues
le carrefour de l'apprentissage le
carrefour de la francophonie à quelques
heures de vol de nombreux territoires
seront peut-être des perspectives pour
bien des réunionnais
[Musique]